premier match de la saison ce samedi 21
janvier pour les templiers d'elancourt
rétrogradé en deuxième division cette
saison
les élans courtois recevez les vikings
de villeneuve d'ascq sous une
température glaciale
le match débute mal pour les rouges avec
deux touchdown encaissés dans le premier
quart temps on a eu un peu de mal à se
mettre dans le match au début il est
normal parce qu'on a plein de nouveaux
nouveaux joueurs c'est pas la même
intensité
c'est pas le même c'est pas la même
chose que les matches de pré saison les
entraînements donc des consignes mulumba
la route est bien lancée on a réussi à
trouver un petit rythme après avoir
laissé passer le blizzard les templiers
se reprennent et marc 29.3 quart temps
devant leur public
score final 29 à 13 le but c'était de
réussir à enchaîner les actions pour
créer des drive avec le de la dynamique
créée un élan pour pouvoir utiliser
notre physique enchaîné vite les actions
qu'ils aient pas temps de se remettre en
place et qu'il soit fatigué rapidement
et on a vu qu appartement on a réussi à
se mettre en route il n'arrivait plus à
tenir le rythme et à partir de là on a
réussi à prendre la mesure et rond après
cette première journée les templiers
sont deuxièmes du championnat avec le
même nombre de points que les cayman du
mans mais le directeur sportif des
templiers veut que son équipe continue à
progresser pour espérer remonter en
première division dès cette saison
continue continue de gagner j'ai
continué on a commencé avec un magma
franchisés sur un deuxième faut
confirmer et puis chaque match un match
à la fois c'est pas parce qu'on a gagné
ce match là qu'on gagnera jeu suivant et
c'est pas parce que parce qu'on gagne le
suivant que mes nerfs après sait rien et
à qui il faut continuer de travailler
rien lâcher prochain match dimanche 29
janvier à 14 heures sur le terrain des
corsaires d'evry